[Música]
uno de los filósofos
alain de botton recientemente dijo hay
que reconocer que la industria
que les guste de los viajes no hace el
mejor de los trabajos a servirnos y que
éste aporta el mundo en categorías
materiales casi por completo y que éste
no cumple con las necesidades de nuestra
alma
creo que todos aquí nos gusta viajar
creo que creo que a casi todo el mundo
le gusta viajar y pues una de las cosas
en las que pensamos usualmente cuando
vamos a viajar
es el lugar el lugar eso es lo primero
que se nos viene a la mente
especialmente qué tan exótico puede ser
ese lugar
creo que
desde mi punto de vista eso es una forma
demasiado material de tomar los viajes
hay una hay una teoría que yo tengo que
podríamos que yo la uso la uso mucho y
creo que
creo que lo que son los viajes podrían
servirnos a nosotros como una forma de
terapia qué quiero decir con esto lo que
quiero dar a entender es que en muchas
ocasiones cuando estamos viajando o
cuando queremos viajar lo primero que
hacemos es pensar en la forma exterior
de viajar como por ejemplo pensamos
demasiado en el hotel en los gastos
pensamos bastante en las cosas que vamos
a ir a hacer y no pensamos tanto en que
vamos a conseguir de ese viaje entonces
yo pienso que eso es un grave error si
vamos a gastar tanto dinero cuando
estemos viajando
saquemos el jugo de verdad ese viaje y
hagamos de este viaje una terapia
entonces cómo podemos hacer eso cuando
nosotros estamos viajando quería
hacerles saber que muchas veces las
personas tenemos una idea
solo los seres humanos poseemos virtudes
yo creo que eso es un grave error
fielmente no creo que sea cierto los
lugares a donde sea que vayamos también
pueden poseer lo que son virtudes no
solamente los seres humanos lo poseemos
sino que también
los lugares un ejemplo bastante claro de
lo que quiero decir es que podríamos
utilizar por ejemplo a una persona que
supongamos una persona que es tímida y
esta persona de alguna forma u otra
quiere hacerse sentir más extrovertida
quiere abrirse más quiere explorar más
su personalidad quiere entenderse a sí
misma en fin una persona tímida está
buscando la forma de conocerse mejor y
poder compartir más con las demás
personas entonces para que ella pueda
utilizar los viajes como una forma de
terapia lo que ella podría hacer es
viajar a brasil
ella se estará preguntando pero como si
yo soy una persona bastante tímida cómo
voy a viajar a brasil en temporada de
carnaval un ejemplo que les voy a poner
en brasil brasil es conocido por los
carnavales por las mujeres exóticas
bailan como la vestimenta extrovertida
es un país bastante alegre entonces una
persona que está buscando mejorarse a sí
misma podría utilizar ese viaje a brasil
como terapia porque allí de alguna forma
u otra va aprende
a darse cuenta a conocerse a sí misma y
no solamente darse cuenta sino que
estaría aprendiendo a cómo desenvolverse
en su entorno
posiblemente le darían ganas de bailar
de expresarse
[Música]
de hacer cosas que usualmente cuando
estamos en casa no hacemos creo que
muchos de nosotros no dejamos salir
muchas partes de nuestra personalidad
cuando nos encontramos en el lugar donde
vivimos porque estamos atados a la
rutina nos preocupa demasiado lo que las
demás personas estén pensando de
nosotros y eso de alguna forma u otra
nos ata a seguir siendo lo que en
realidad somos entonces cuando viajamos
cuando viajamos dejamos que las partes
ocultas de nuestra psiquis y nuestra
psicología
dejen salir especialmente porque
conocemos a muchas personas en el camino
que comparten sus historias con nosotros
conocemos a llegamos a encontrarnos en
muchas situaciones que básicamente nos
están forzando
actuar o pensar o decir cosas que
usualmente no haríamos mientras estamos
en casa quería contarles una anécdota
muy personal mía en el a finales del
2013 me aceptaron en la universidad
italiana de la facultad de economía
comercio y negocios
para que italia pero italia bello y un
domingo recuerdo que mi mami tenía día
libre ese día ya no para trabajar tenía
día libre y nos dijo vamos a pasear y
pues estuvimos en varias ciudades y al
día siguiente yo tenía examen y como el
domingo anterior me la pasé viajando de
una ciudad a otra con mi hermana mi mamá
me la pasé increíble
recuerdo
que este domingo fue un día bastante
cansado estamos viajando a muchas
ciudades
la verdad que fue increíble fuego creo
que uno de los mejores días de mi vida y
pues llegué tan cansada ese domingo que
al día siguiente el lunes yo tiene un
examen muy importante era el último
examen del trimestre
como el día anterior me la pasé viajando
no había estudiado mucho me levanté
tardísimo y ni siquiera escuchar la
alarma usualmente la ciudad donde yo
estaba viviendo se llama pistoia y de
pistoia firenze son dos horas de viajes
son como diez ciudades de diferencia
entonces mientras estaba alistando me di
cuenta que era tardísimo me había dado
cuenta que no me acordaba bien de lo que
era lo que me venía en el examen estaba
súper preocupada
me subí al tren de pisto y perdonen me
subí al bus de pistoia porque para
llegar a la estación de firenze son dos
autobuses tomes otro autobús es súper
concentrada en mi lectura
eventualmente llegó a la estación y me
subí al primer tren que decía fíjense
porque fíjense era la universidad donde
yo estaba estudiando no me había fijado
que el tren en realidad iba para fíjense
pero no paraba incidente entonces me
subí al tren me puse a estudiar estaba
muy concentrada lo que estaba haciendo y
eventualmente sentí que la gente se
levantó y se fue de tren pero como yo
estaba tan concentrada lo que yo estaba
haciendo que en realidad
no me fijé si el tren se paró siguió
pues para mi sorpresa
cuando se me enciende el foco y decido
mirad a mi alrededor me doy cuenta que
estoy completamente sola en un vagón
sola completamente sola y me paro y no
hay nadie en el vagón solamente estoy yo
decido ir al vagón que está atrás y no
hay nadie me voy al bar un número 5678
llegue hasta el 12 y no había nadie yo
estaba completamente sola en el tren
debo decirles que hasta ese punto
comencé a sentirme preocupada no sabía
qué hacer me dirigí a la estación del
tren la primera donde se encuentra el
capo treno y comencé a presionar los
botones para el monitor para ver si él
me decía alguien me contesta
y los presionaba y presiona el botón y
nadie me contestaba cuando me doy cuenta
el tren se paró se paró por completo y
me asomo a la izquierda y me asomo a la
derecha y estoy en medio
y carriles que se extendían hasta lo que
los podía ver básicamente estaba en
medio de la nada comencé a llorar
comencé a llorar no sabía qué hacer
comencé a llamar a mi mami decirle mami
estoy en una ciudad que no conozco estoy
sola el capote no no me contesta que
hago en ese momento la llamada se cayó
yo no sabía qué hacer pues me senté ahí
convencida de que iba a perder mi examen
y me sentía a pensar que iba a hacer que
con que su saliva a salir al profesor y
pues eventualmente el tren comenzó a
moverse a todo esto nadie ha salido del
primer vagón a explicarme qué pasaba y
no me quedó de otra más que sentarme y
pues esperar a ver dónde me iba a llevar
ese tren
eventualmente el tren llegó hasta la
estación que yo quería me baje estaba
estaba muy preocupada por mi examen y
cuando me bajé mire que los dos campos
frenos se estaban bajando también
obviamente yo estaba muy molesta porque
yo les estaba hablando les estaba
diciendo estaba intentando comunicarme
con ellos para que me dirán qué era lo
que estaba pasando y ninguno me
contestaba
estaba muy molesta en ese momento y pues
creo que hasta
les dije que era muy responsable de
parte de ellos no atender a los la
tripulación entonces muy sonriente mente
eran gemelos eran gemelos los campo tren
o muy suficientemente me dieron dijo el
primer monitor no funciona por eso no le
pudimos contestar y no pudimos abrirle
la puerta para que para explicarle lo
que estaba pasando porque la puerta
estaba en mal estado
en ese momento sentí mucha pena sentí
mucha pena y aprendí una gran lección en
ese momento la lección que aprendí es
que en muchas ocasiones mientras se está
viajando tenemos la tendencia a
sentirnos en peligro porque nos
encontramos en un ambiente desconocido
tendemos a exagerar lo que estamos
viendo y no estamos muy conscientes de
que es simplemente un viaje tendemos
tenemos la tendencia a no a no prestar
mucha atención a nuestro entorno después
de esa actitud y de haberme mostrado de
esta forma ante esa gente en un país
ajeno también aprendí que en muchas
ocasiones tenemos la tendencia a creer
de que en realidad no se nos quiere
ayudar cuando en muchas ocasiones sin
darnos cuenta o si estar o sin estar
conscientes de eso no
no vemos que no es que no se nos quiera
ayudar sino que simplemente a veces no
se puede
una de las cosas más importantes que he
aprendido mientras estoy viajando porque
debo decir que admito que los fines de
semana si me gusta salir de viaje que
los fines de semana por lo general no
pasó en ceiba es que cuando se está
viajando se aprende tantas cosas del
entorno se aprende tanto de tanta gente
especialmente cuando se viaja a otro
país nos damos cuenta que las personas
hacen las cosas de forma diferente a lo
que nosotros estamos acostumbrados a
hacer y eso de alguna forma u otra abre
nuestra mente abre nuestra mente
grandemente y déjenme contarles que hay
un lugar en específico como mencioné
anteriormente yo creo que los lugares
tienen virtudes y pueden dejarnos una
enseñanza psicológica me gustaría me
encantaría por ejemplo tomar a honduras
como un ejemplo lo que estoy intentando
decir honduras tristemente es uno de los
países con más tasas con tasas más altas
de homicidio en el mundo
y hay una mala infraestructura del
gobierno hay bastante pobreza es
bastante ignorancia y el 40% de los de
los habitantes de honduras son menores
de 15 años estas personas no tienen
acceso a agua potable educación y
tristemente es lo más triste del caso
que estas personas que no tienen
educación son las personas que es que
más hijos tienen entonces como estas
personas no han tenido educación todo
todo lo que ellos cree saber es lo que
se les enseña a sus hijos entonces esto
funciona como una especie de círculo
vicioso que se va dando y estos niños
van creciendo no tienen la educación y
lo mismo que le enseñan a que se le fue
enseñado a ellos es lo que enseñan a sus
a sus a sus hijos entonces lo que sucede
con esto es que esto se va dando en un
círculo
y esta es la gente que eventualmente
llega
a poblar nuestro país entonces
cuando uno se da cuenta de la situación
tan precaria y pobreza crónica en la que
esta gente vive
aquí viendo lo que quería explicarles
cuando uno se da cuenta de la situación
en la que otras personas viven es aquí
cuando los músculos de la apreciación
los músculos del entendimiento los
músculos del amor hacia el prójimo es
aquí cuando estos músculos emocionales
tienen que ejercitarse
estas personas tristemente casi ninguna
de ellas logra salir de la situación en
la que se encuentran para una persona
que tiene educación media para una
persona que tiene una educación media
alta nosotros que si tenemos acceso a
todas las cosas que de las que estas
personas fueron privadas allí es cuando
nosotros deberíamos aprender a valorar
lo que tenemos otro país que se puede
tomar
un perfecto ejemplo es dinamarca este
país
este país es un país nórdico de europa y
saben en este país el sol solamente
brilla 1540 horas al año
el sol es escaso en este país sin
embargo el gobierno ha sido muy
inteligente y ha tomado la decisión de
utilizar otros tipos de energía para
poder crear energía eléctrica de su país
esto me dice que es el que el gobierno
sabe cómo tomar excelentes decisiones
para su pueblo lo que me llama mucho la
atención de este país es que además de
que utilizan otra fuente de energía para
poder crear electricidad en los hogares
es que no existen la epoc ismo
por nepotismo quiero dar a entender qué
el gobierno las personas que se
encuentran en el gobierno no dan méritos
ni dan cargos favorables a sus
familiares amigos simplemente porque lo
sean sino que simplemente el que esté en
el gobierno es porque se ha ganado estar
en ese lugar entonces podríamos tomar a
dinamarca como un ejemplo para aprender
a pensar en el futuro para aprender a
encaminarnos y saber qué es lo que
queremos de nosotros mismos y cómo
lograrlo quería hacerles saber también
hay otro lugar que también me llama
mucho la atención para poner como
ejemplo en mi charla y esta sería las
ruinas de copán
las ruinas de copán
si ustedes han viajado a ese lugar si
han estado allí anteriormente
muy pocas veces cuando vamos a un lugar
nos fijamos en las fisuras nos fijamos
en las fisuras del lugar
nos fijamos en las fisuras del lugar las
ruinas de copán es inmensos y se han
tomado una fotografía allí se evada se
van a dar cuenta que la gente se ve
pequeña inmensamente pequeña entonces la
psicología la enseñanza que este lugar
puede dejarnos es que es bueno sentirse
pequeño de vez en cuando muchas veces
creemos que sentirse pequeño está
asociado con algo negativo pero es muy
importante aprender a sentirnos pequeños
porque el ser humano por naturaleza
tiende a exagerar su propia importancia
dentro del mundo entonces una enseñanza
importante que las ruinas de copán
podrían dejarnos es que el mundo va a
seguir girando muchísimo tiempo después
de que nosotros hayamos muerto y esto de
alguna forma u otra nos va a hacer
sentir
deberíamos aprender esto debería
enseñarnos a sentirnos pequeños y no
pequeños de una forma negativa o
humillado sino que pequeños de una forma
positiva en la que sabemos qué
no hay que angustiarse que los viajes
por más caros que puedan ser muchas
veces deberíamos adoptarlo como una
forma de vida y que esteban está
contribuiría de una forma u otra a lo
que es nuestra enseñanza psicológica es
muy importante saber a qué lugar se
quiere viajar para que éste pueda
contribuir con el lugar interior sólo
así el viaje exterior se convierte tan
importante como el interior gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]